this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god
am i in love with eight sleep good sleep
is the ultimate
game changer more than 30 percent of
americans struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device called
the pod pro cover by eight sleep it's
the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this so i used it and
here we are
add the pod pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users
fall asleep up to 32 percent faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
percent and get more restful sleep
overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution
for enhanced recovery so you can take on
the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get two hundred
and fifty dollars off of the pod pro
cover that's a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim
or use code tim that's eight all spelled
out
e-i-g-h-t sleep dot com
slash tim or use coupon code tim
t-i-m-eight sleep dot com slash tim
for 200 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by
headspace headspace is your daily dose
of mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2 000 plus
apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million
downloads so if people keep telling you
to try meditation and you're like when
would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers a really
light lift and a lot of features
to keep you going which is part of the
reason that i've used headspace
for years now so whatever the situation
headspace can really help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation for you need
some help falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions their
members swear by and for parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can do with your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder andy i think
it's puddicum could be putty comb i'm
not sure but former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic voice
imaginable
and i did a three minute meditation
something like that it's
easy it's fundamental and it always puts
me in a better
space so i'm going through the basics
even though i've meditated for years i'm
going through the basics once again
and i would suggest to anyone that they
consider starting there
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
mindfulness that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere we all
want to feel happier
we all want more peace and headspace is
meditation made
simple go to headspace.com tim
that's headspace.com tim for a free one
month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace
this is the best deal offered right now
for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim at today
altitude i can run flat out for a half
mile before my hands start to shake
can i ask you a personal question
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
and my guest today is one of my favorite
guests michael pollan
you know him on twitter at michael
pollan p-o-l-l-a-n he is the author of
eight books
including how to change your mind which
has changed many minds indeed
cooked food rules in defensive food the
omnivore's dilemma and the botany of
desire all of which
were new york times bestsellers a
longtime contributor to the new york
times magazine paulin teaches writing at
harvard university and the university of
california berkeley
in 2010 time magazine named him one of
the 100 most influential people
in the world his newest book is this is
your mind
on plants you can find him at
michaelpollen.com on twitter and
instagram
michaelpollen michael.pollen
respectively
michael welcome back to the show thank
you tim good to be back
i thought we would begin in the
beginning go back to the archives
and i came across something titled
my two gardens and i would like to ask
you about
your first garden or childhood garden
since that will be i think a great
launching point for many many topics in
our conversation
yeah well gardening is really the germ
of all my work
it's funny uh the the piece you're
alluding to appeared in forbes
but it was an adaptation from my first
book
a second nature a gardener's education
and this came out in 91
and it was really the story of my
learning how to garden which was also
the story of my learning how to think
about nature
and my engagement with the natural world
i gardened as a little kid
i had a garden when i was eight years
old i called it a farm
and it was right along the uh the side
the edge of my parents suburban
tract house on long island and anytime i
could and i had a kid across the street
who would do the heavy labor for me he
was you know
always happy to do what i told him to do
and and i would do the planting
and uh if i could grow two or three
strawberries i'd put them in a dixie cup
and sell them to my mother
so it was a business too but my love of
gardening
came from my grandfather my maternal
grandfather who was a russian immigrant
who had come here to escape conscription
basically in tsarist russia and he came
in
1917 he started out selling potatoes
from a horse-drawn cart on long island
and gradually got into the produce
business and became a wholesaler
and then started buying farms the farms
of the farmers he knew who wanted to get
out of the business on long island
turn those into shopping centers it was
a classic story but he
never lost his love of produce you know
he grew in his garden
it was huge i mean there were just two
of them and
they grew enough to have a farm stand
and
i loved working in his garden and i
loved harvesting more than anything
and i didn't have much in common with
him except this in fact
we didn't get along that well through
the teenage years he thought i was too
much of a hippie
and my hair was too long and he really
was you know kind of a
right wing guy but in the garden we
really connected
and that experience of growing something
and then actually creating something of
value that you could
eat or sell in my case to my mother
was was just so gratifying and there
began my love of plants
and so this first book was an attempt to
look at what what i was learning in the
garden and i was making a lot of
mistakes
i got into a a war with a woodchuck
and in fact that was the first essay i
wrote about
this woodchuck i planted my seedlings
one spring we had bought we bought a
house in cornwall connecticut
when i was 30 i guess and i started
gardening on the weekends there
and every time i planted this woodchuck
would emerge from his burrow
and wipe out everything i'd planted so i
went to war i mean i did you know i
found his
his burrow i did a lot of research i
understood that
i found that they're actually even
though they look like slobs if you've
ever seen a woodchuck or a groundhog
same thing they're fat and they can
barely see and
they kind of tootle around with their
belly you know scraping the ground
um but they're they're they're clean you
know they're
obsessed about cleanliness and so i i
poured molasses and creosote down their
hole
and because i found the the hole and
thinking that they would be disgusted
and move away but they just dug a new
hole right next to it
and i escalated this war it was like
caddyshack
it was a lot like caddyshack when that
movie came out i identified completely
with bill murray
but i got into this escalating series of
steps
i got angrier and angrier that you know
here i was the more evolved creature
with the bigger brain
being thwarted by this idiotic you know
rodent i don't know if they're rodents
but i thought it was a rodent
so it was my horticultural vietnam
basically and i kept getting in deeper
and deeper and deeper
at one point i was driving along the the
road nearby and i found a flattened
woodchuck on the side of the street
and i had an idea and i got a piece of
cardboard and i scooped the
the roadkill onto the cardboard brought
it home
shoved it into the hole thinking this
would send a message you know it was
kind of like don corleone you know
with the horse's head in the godfather
didn't work i was finally reduced to
pouring
you know half a gallon of gasoline down
the borough
and lighting a match and throwing that
in there
and i and i poured the gasoline down i
know people think of me as an
environmentalist writer
um and uh and i and i just
gave some time for the gasoline to go
through all the different rooms and i
had an image in my head because they
have all these different rooms they have
a latrine they have a food room
they have these elaborate burrows then i
threw a match
and i never took physics in college i
was an english major
and i didn't realize that fire would not
go away from oxygen as i wanted it to go
so the flames shot the other way and
there was this
fountain of flames that comes out of
this hole in my garden
and i was you know almost incinerated
myself thrown back
and shocked into a recognition that this
is not the way to deal with the natural
world
[Music]
and what i was doing was very much in
sync with what our species does when we
feel thwarted by nature
which is we feel we have the right and
we're the smarter creature
and i realized at that moment and i
wrote an essay about this
originally appeared in the new york
times magazine that
what's happening in the garden is a
microcosm
of our engagement with the natural world
for better and worse
and in this case worse and that i could
use the garden
and gardening as a place to explore our
relationship to nature
in general american nature writers go to
the wilderness right they go to the they
go to the desert they go to the forest
they go to places where
you just stand back and look but in the
garden like the farm
we have no choice but to engage we have
to act if we're going to get what we
want
so how do we act what are the ethics
what's the morality
and that began this path of you know
examining our relationship to other
species in the garden including plants
i am going to come back to gardening
quite selfishly to
ask you for some advice because i am
planning on
over the next year doing my first
gardening
now we probably don't have the scope
to explore that fully in this
conversation but just to plant that seed
pun intended i'm going to
say you now have some land i do you have
some land you do
yes and excellent we're going to return
to the concept of garden as microcosm
very shortly but before we do
you could write on anything
that you choose and this is your mind on
plants
how did you arrive at this particular
book
because you have carte blanche you could
do whatever you want i mean
it's my first love you know writing
about plants and my interest in
psychoactives
and my interests in plants kind of come
together in this book
in botany of desire there was a chapter
which is a book that looks at
or the symbiotic relationship of people
and plants how they change us and we
change them
and i have always been fascinated by
this one weird particular use to which
we put plants
and this is true for most cultures
probably 95 percent of cultures around
the world have some plant or fungus they
use to change consciousness
to achieve transcendent experience
that's a very peculiar thing
because if you think about it why would
that be adaptive
it could be the opposite you know when
we take drugs
when we change consciousness we're more
vulnerable to accident
to predation we lose our a lot of our
defenses
so there's a danger in changing
consciousness
in a radical way anyway yet we do it and
people have always done it the only
culture that's been documented that
doesn't have a plan to change
consciousness are the inuit
in greenland because nothing good grows
where they live
that's the only reason that human desire
has been
fascinating me since i first grew
cannabis when i was you know quite young
so i wanted to do a deep dive into it
and i wanted to look at
three plants that produce important
psychoactives
an upper a downer and an outer as i call
it so i chose
caffeine which is we don't even think of
that as a drug
as a psychoactive as an addictive
substance but of course
it is and i have it right here i'm
consuming it as we speak
and there's two of us i'm holding up a
mug of coffee
and then the other two i chose were
opium which has a particular
relevance now because of the opiate
crisis but
that is actually a piece that i wrote
many many years ago at the height of the
drug war and that piece is kind of a
parable of the absurdity of the drug war
that we can talk about in
in more detail and then the the third
one i wanted to do a psychedelic and a
psychedelic i hadn't written about
and that nobody's written much about
since aldous huxley and that is
mescaline
and my interest in that one grew out of
all the reporting i did
in the psychedelic community and asking
people what's your favorite psychedelic
and to my surprise the answer i heard
more than any other was
mescaline and nobody seems to have it
nobody seems to use it anymore
and yet it was everybody's favorite it
was the master
material somebody told me and i remember
i don't think i should use his name but
somebody we both know who's younger than
i am
saying why have you been hiding this
from us for all these years the hippies
were hiding the best drug
keeping it all for themselves yeah
so anyway so i i chose those three as
representing different
dimensions of our relationship to
psychoactive plants
and to remind people that this is part
of our
engagement with the natural world as
much as eating is
as much as you know clothing ourselves
and fibers
produced by nature we use plants to
alter our minds and
how incredible is it that plants have
evolved
the precise molecular key to unlock your
consciousness
that's really weird that's i think it's
one of the great mysteries of
of nature so anyway i thought it'd be
fun to write about this book is more of
a romp than the last one
you know there's i mean yes there's
science in history but it's
these are really personal stories of my
engagement with these plants
and what these plants have to teach us
so
i wanted to do something that was very
close to my heart and that would be
enjoyable
and take me back to the garden were
there any other plants or molecules that
came
close as candidates but ultimately
didn't make the cut
did you consider others yeah
i did well for psychedelics you know i
thought about
writing about 5-meo dmt i thought about
it of course it's not a plan
it's a toad i could have done salvia
divinorum you know there were a whole
lot but i wanted something that had a
really rich history
that has changed the course of history
and mescaline has
and not just for our culture but for
native american culture we can talk more
about that
so actually it wasn't like when i was
writing botany and desire which is a
portrait of four plants that i had like
10 i could have done and i had to settle
on corn and apples and
tulips and cannabis there was something
that loom large about these three to me
caffeine because that is really the drug
i have the deepest
involvement with and it was actually
roland griffith
who we both know who the psychedelic
researcher at hopkins
who you know before he started working
on psilocybin he was the world's leading
researcher on caffeine
and i remember the first time i
interviewed him i saw all these books
about coffee in his
in his study and i was very curious
about his interest
he gave me the idea for the experiment
at the heart of that piece which is he
said
you can never understand your
relationship to a drug to a psychoactive
substance unless you get off it
and stand back and look at it because if
you're
an addict he doesn't use the word addict
but if you're dependent
you will never see it accurately and so
that was the challenge to me
which is at the heart of that piece is
like could i abstain from coffee for
three months without going
crazy and losing my my livelihood as a
writer
which i nearly did we're going to dig
into
all of those it strikes me that those
three as you noted the the three options
that you chose
allow you to do in a sense what you do
best which is take these layers of the
scientific the philosophical the
political
journalistic the historical and
layer them properly right so not all
candidates
are created equal in that sense no and
they don't all have the they don't all
have quite enough layers
right i i think that's exactly right and
that is
key to my method which is not to
privilege any one
way of analyzing something i don't think
the scientists have all the answers
i don't think the poets have all the
answers but if you multiply lenses
you suddenly get the full picture and
that's what i love doing as a writer
so you have many types of stories
in this book you have the fascinating
the hilarious
you also have as you know from my my
well caffeinated texts
to you at one point stories that i
consider quite terrifying
and i wanted to read this is from page
16 and 17. i'm just going to read
a snippet and then i want to talk about
jim hogshear or hogshire and i want you
to tell
that story so this is on page 16.
in an april 2016 article in harper's
magazine
legalize it all dan baum recounted an
interview that he conducted with john is
it erlichman or
erlichmann
as you will recall was president nixon's
domestic policy advisor he served time
in federal prison for his role in
watergate
bound came to talk to erickman about the
drug war of which he was a key architect
and this is this is uh one paragraph and
then we're going to hop back to you
this is a quote from erlang quote you
want to know what this was
really all about erlichman then
explained that the nixon white house
quote
had two enemies the anti-war left and
black people this is a direct quote
we knew we couldn't make it illegal to
be either against the war or black but
by getting the public to associate the
hippies with marijuana and blacks the
heroin and then criminalizing both
heavily
we could disrupt those communities we
could arrest their leaders raid their
homes break up their meetings and vilify
them night after night on the evening
news
did we know we were lying about the
drugs of course we did end quote
that is an insane just the fact that
those are spoken words quoted
is incredible to me yeah
that's all you need to know about the
drug war there it is in a colonel
the real reason for it the fact that it
had nothing to do with public health did
he mention public health did he mention
people
suffering with addiction no uh or
overdosing
no it was simply political and we've
known long before nixon that
the drugs that get criminalized are the
ones that are used by troublesome
populations i mean the reason they went
after cannabis was because of mexicans
and blacks who were using it and
the drug war has always been about
politics and there is about as blunt
a revelation of that fact as you can
imagine
yeah i remember reading that and uh that
that quote got quite a bit of publicity
when it came out
unfortunately baum died and i wanted to
interview him about that interview
and he died last spring or last fall and
i wasn't able to
but it's i think there are two things
where
whatever you think of the drug war it
collapses when you look at them
one is that looking at nixon really
starts at 1970
there are his motives he needs to
criminalize these two
troublesome populations the other is the
fact that
while we were fighting this drug war
which reaches really its peak in the
clinton administration
you know whatever you think about
clinton his crime bill led to mandatory
minimum sentences
and led to mass incarceration and
the drug war was being fought with
particular vigor during
the 90s and it was all part of clinton's
triangulating to the right and this is
part of the story i tell in the
in the opium chapter is that while the
dea
and other authorities were going after
small-time drug dealers and
and individuals even trying to grow a
little opium for themselves
purdue pharma was introducing in 1996
oxycontin and leading to
eventually the opiate crisis because
they marketed
opiates so aggressively and convinced
the medical establishment that pain was
being under-medicated and that this was
a safer non-addictive opiate when they
knew
precisely the opposite this has come out
in court cases so
the biggest public health crisis during
the period of the drug war
involved legal drugs not illegal drugs
so you know the government was looking
at the wrong problem
and the fda had approved oxycontin and
yes many people who began with legal
opiates
like most heroin users eventually
transition because they can't get access
to legal opiates and then they
transition to
street drugs and then bump into things
like fentanyl
and the likelihood or possibility of
overdose
but i think nothing points up the
absurdity of the drug war then
the two things that were happening in
the year 1996 that i wrote about
one of which you haven't heard about
which is jim hogshire
and the other is you know the opioid
crisis
so this is a very personal i mean the
opiate
or i mean it really isn't i guess opiate
opioid
discussion is a very personal one for me
uh because
my best friend from growing up
on long island died of a fentanyl
overdose so i have
firsthand experience with how easily
these and this is obviously simplified
but super strength
opioids can do damage i know another
person who had an accidental
overdose of fentanyl so this sort of the
extent
and growth of this problem is pretty
staggering i mean at some point in the
book you compare
the stats kind of then and now
and it's it's really unbelievable and
i think to to jump into the microcosm to
explore the macrocosm
jim hogshire could you please tell me
yeah
and tell the listeners about jim and how
he came onto your radar
yeah so this story about
growing my own opium began with
an editor friend sending me an
underground press book
called opium for the masses i was
writing columns about my garden the
pieces that became second nature
and my editor a fellow austinite named
paul tuff
said hey this book is like up your alley
and he sends me
opium for the masses and i read it and
it was like
this is so cool i can grow my own opium
you know and like most gardeners
i just want to see if i can do it you
know i wasn't interested in consuming
opium now it just
just for clarity because opium is going
to sound scary to a lot of people but
when you say grow opium what do you mean
okay it does sound scary i guess uh it
means growing
poppies papa verse omniferum which is an
annual poppy you can buy the seeds
at a garden center you can order them
online
you can scrape them off a poppy seed
bagel those are poppy seeds
and they grow this plant this beautiful
plant with with paper thin petals and
this
beautiful seed pod after the petals fall
off
and this gorgeous lettuce-like leaves
when the petals drop and that seed pod
forms and it looks
like a piece of sculpture if you slit
that
green skin of that seed pod with your
fingernail
or with a blade and wait 60 seconds you
will see this white
latexy looking sap emerge
leak out of it bleed from it that is
opium
pure and simple and it dries brown and
you can
roll it off and you have opium now
you need a few thousand of those pods to
get a usable amount of opium
if you do it that way and it takes a
it's a lot of work and that's one of the
reasons
it's grown in places with very cheap
child labor who can go through
fields slitting every pot but it grows
just as well in your garden
anyway he was explaining all this which
i didn't know and
he was saying a better much better way
to use it is to make a tea
from the poppy seed heads and just let
them dry
put them in a coffee mill or grinder
somehow and soak them in hot water
and you'll have this tea and in fact
this tea is drunk in the arab world
during funerals and as a mild painkiller
you know it's not a
big experience but it's a very mild
narcotic for taking because
for taking the set lifting the sadness
yeah
so i thought well you know this i get a
column out of this this could be kind of
fun
so i order some seeds and i start
communicating with hawkshire i got a
hold of his
email and asking some questions and did
he have any seeds he could spare
and we're going back and forth and then
suddenly i get a call
from my friend paul who i don't know how
he had this information
that jim has been arrested and charged
with manufacturing narcotics
the only evidence the police have this
happens in seattle they
bust into his apartment they bring a
swat team
you know 20 guys with guns and you know
ninja suits
and this guy is sitting there with his
wife and they bust in
and throw him up against the wall what
do they get him with
he's got a bunch of dried poppies
from the flora shop okay you've seen
these
flower heads in every flora shop because
they look beautiful in an arrangement
and his book his book proves his intent
to take those poppy seeds and make a
narcotic with this is where things get
super crazy
yeah please continue to expand on this
so it turns out that it's perfectly
legal to grow
opium poppies possess the seeds and grow
the poppies
unless you have knowledge that you are
growing
a scheduled substance in which case the
same act
miraculously gets turned into a federal
crime of manufacturing narcotics that
carries a five to twenty year
sentence so all your listeners have just
endangered millions of people
no plausible they've lost it because if
they uh you know if there's any record
that they heard this podcast and they're
growing opium poppies they are at some
risk
the risk was a lot greater in the 90s at
the height of the drug war i might say
so so suddenly when i hear he's been
arrested
and he is in jail and his wife is in
jail
i'm like oh [ __ ] i've got this paper
trail or this digital trail
between him and me because we're
exchanging email and they
i'm sure seized his computer now what do
i do do i rip these things out
and thus began this summer of like fear
and loathing
uh as i as he's going through the court
process
and i'm trying to determine how risky my
little
crop of poppies are and so i start
reporting and i start calling dea agents
and and the locals police and i say you
know and asking them questions about
so i want to grow some papaver
somniferum and is it is it okay
and you know they would say well yeah if
it's just for scenery looks as one put
it to me and i said well what if i slit
the
poppy heads and he said oh then we'll
bust down your door
and i did learn that there was this
quiet crackdown going on
all across america led by the dea
who probably alerted by jim's book
wanted to make sure this didn't become a
fad
because the myth had been spread that
you couldn't grow
opium poppies in america it had to be
turkey or afghanistan and that
simply wasn't true it was a cash crop
for many people in the south for many
years
and it turns out there was this
crackdown going on that that dea agents
were visiting florist shops
to tell them to stop carrying dried
poppy heads
they were calling seed companies telling
them to remove them even though they
were perfectly legal
you know it was a a tense summer for me
in the end
i wrote an article about my experience
and about jim hawkshire
i submitted it to harper's magazine who
had commissioned it it was a long piece
i'd worked on it for a year it was like
15
000 words and i said to my editor look
we have to get this piece lawyered
because i you know i'm confessing to a
federal crime here
because i did describe not just growing
the opium
poppies but making poppy tea and
something called loudonum which is
how opium was used in the 19th century
basically you dissolve the uh
the poppy heads in alcohol so all you do
is crush them and put them in uh
vodka and that makes them much stronger
i learned from a usda ethnobotanist that
yeah
if you really want to get a strong opium
hit dissolve it in alcohol not
you know not water but jim didn't
include that because he was a muslim
and he doesn't drink so the lawyer so
they they sent it to a very prominent
criminal defense lawyer in the state of
connecticut and who
who is they at the time oh harper's
magazine the publisher
i say please we have to get this piece
lawyer before we publish it and he said
oh i've got a friend who's
you know a criminal defense lawyer in
bridgeport where there's a lot of
crime to be defended and this guy reads
the piece drives up to our house in
cornwall my son who's four at the time
is off in daycare and the lawyer and his
young associates sit us down and say
well you can't publish this piece this
is a confession
on the basis of this piece and nothing
more they could
arrest you on charges of manufacturing
narcotics
and possession of narcotics they could
also take your house away
under the asset forfeiture laws which
are still in effect they've been diluted
somewhat but they're still in effect
if a piece of property or a car
is involved in the commission of a drug
crime
the police may seize it and the standard
of proof
is not beyond a reasonable doubt it's
i forget what the one there's one
standard below that but it's not a very
high standard
so there are many cases where even
though
if you had a son or daughter who was
growing marijuana in your backyard
even if you didn't know about it your
backyard could be guilty of a drug crime
and it could be
forfeited and these laws stand there
they're absolutely outrageous
and so they could take your house and
basically wreck your life
and my wife and i are like turning white
i mean first of all that we have a
criminal defense lawyer
in our living room you know because of
some gardening crime i committed
was amazing and so i thought well
that's it a year's work down the drain i
was a freelance writer i was
counting on that paycheck when the
publisher of harpers
who is a man named rick mcarthur very
wealthy man who kind of keeps the
magazine afloat he's descended from the
macarthurs of macarthur foundation
he's a champion of the first amendment
when he hears that this
lawyer has advised against publication
his immediate response is
we need a new lawyer and so he hires
a very prominent first amendment lawyer
in new york named victor kovner who
represented the nation
and a bunch of magazines and is you know
one of the big
voices in that world and victor reads
the article and says
in effect you must publish this article
for the good of the republic
this is what the first amendment exists
for this is this is critical commentary
on the drug war
and i'm like really but what about
what about the jailing and the loss of
my house
eventually he says well you could make
it less antagonistic to the government
by removing
two pieces two sections one is your
recipe
where you describe how you make poppy
tea and the other is your
what we would call the trip report where
you describe the effects
he said this is particularly
antagonistic to the government given
their interests
if you take those two sections out i
think your risk is not
nil but it's negligible so
i still wasn't ready to publish because
i still heard that
other lawyer in my ears so i asked rick
if he would protect me
rick mcarthur the publisher and he had
victor
draw up a contract the likes of which no
writer has ever seen
in which he says if you get arrested
we will not only defend you we will pay
your wife
a salary for the whole amount of time it
takes for you to defend yourself and
and if necessary serve your sentence and
if they take your
house we'll buy you a comparable new one
so i was completely indemnified but
still terrified
and that's what we did and we published
it and it was a cover story in
uh 97 called opium made easy
and uh nothing happened
the piece comes out i mean victor
calculated they wouldn't want to go
after a well-funded magazine
and they would look really stupid doing
it and unlike jim hawkshire they left me
alone
and that's because i had the protection
of uh of you know
a reputable publication so i've always
wanted to publish the piece the way it
was written
and this is another wrinkle it's hard to
recreate the paranoia of
1996-97 around drugs it was a very
different moment
they were busting lots of people there
were 1.1 million arrests in
in 96 for for drug crimes and they were
filling the prisons with people who had
done things like i had done
so i got the offending pages off the
property
i just said to i have a brother-in-law
who's a uh who's a lawyer and i said
could you just take these to your office
or in your safe or wherever uh you know
i just don't want them around
and i got them off my computer i just
kind of cleansed everything of these
you know seven thousand words or five
thousand words i forget how much it was
i realized i now had an opportunity to
publish it the way i wanted it
and so i went looking for the the
missing pages and and my brother-in-law
said i think i came back to you a few
years ago and i searched my house in
connecticut which we still own and
hidden away in this closet i found this
lawyer's brief container you know with
the rubber band around it
and in there was a um purple floppy
drive
i don't know if you remember zip drives
from the late 90s
and they were hard they weren't actually
floppy and on the outside it had a list
of contents
and one was poppy draft and i said oh
i've got it it's here
but i don't have anything to read of zip
drive do you
i mean those are like obsolete media
so i found a computer wizard in a
neighboring town
he said let me see what i've got in my
basement and he found a zip drive
and he was able to get the file off it
and sent it to me
but it's an early microsoft word
file that current microsoft word can't
read
so then i had to find a piece of
software and there is something called
libra
office which will read any microsoft
file from any era
it's free software and there it was and
it popped up on my screen one day
i was able to restore it so that was one
reason to publish it
to restore those pages and i was happy
to be able to do that
and share the recipe and the trip report
with people but the other was
learning later what was going on at the
same moment the same
summer that the dea was going around
terrifying florists and and nurseries
purdue pharma was introducing oxycontin
and the real opiate crisis was beginning
and the government was looking the wrong
way i just thought that that irony was
so
telling that it was time to take another
look so the piece now
is republished in its entirety but also
there's a
shell i built around it about what life
was like in that moment and what was
going on with purdue pharma
in reading that chapter that section
coming back to rick i kind of fell in
love with rick mcarthur
honestly and i know it's described a bit
in the book but
why do you think he offered you all of
those
assurances if you lose your house we'll
buy your house you get put in jail
pay your wife a salary i mean the extent
to which he went
was willing to go to get this published
seems extraordinary was because he had
complete confidence that nothing would
happen was it i know you said he was a
staunch supporter of
first amendment but i can't imagine that
he did this all the time maybe he did
no he didn't i mean he was he's a
crusading
publisher like a crusading journalist
and
i shouldn't speak for him but my guess
is i he was hoping something would
happen
he was hoping i would get arrested this
would put harper's on the map
this would be a you know a giant case he
would take it to the supreme court
and he would you know he has bottomless
pockets i mean
and publishing for him is kind of an
avocation he was always
looking for the big story that harpers
would um
get involved with i mean we saw that
just last year with the harper's letter
around free speech versus the efforts to
curb free speech in the name of various
woke values
he's not afraid of controversy i mean
you shouldn't think of him as publisher
he's he's not a bean counter
although i should say he's incredibly
cheap as a publisher with his employees
but with issues like this he's
incredibly generous
so this is a guy i was lucky to get a
one percent raise every year from
because i was i worked there as an
editor first and fighting
in many ways my writing career began
because i couldn't get a raise at
harpers
and one year i asked louis lapham who
was the editor
instead of a raise this year will you
assign me an article i wanted to get
published in harper's magazine
and i'd been an editor there for a
couple years and he was delighted to do
that instead of having to fight with
rick about money that assignment was my
first garden essay
so i have rick's cheapness to thank for
my writing career
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis
you would have missed out on 50 percent
five zero percent of your returns
don't miss out on the best days in the
market stay invested in a long-term
automated investment portfolio
wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
takes about three minutes to sign up and
then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your
risk appetite and manage it for you at
an incredibly low cost
wealthfront software constantly monitors
your portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride
let the professionals do the work for
you go to wealthfront.com
tim and open a wealthfront investment
account today and you'll get your first
five thousand dollars managed for free
for life that's wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
time
so the opium chapter really opened my
eyes to so many different facets of the
so-called drug war
and the just the arbitrary nature
in some respects although i guess i
should take that back it's not entirely
arbitrary but
the reasons for which certain compounds
are vilified are not always
obvious at first glance because we have
for instance i'm sitting here in austin
texas if you go to austin well i
shouldn't
i don't want people going to hunt this
down but throughout austin
you can find something known as
datura or jimson weed it grows
easily in many many places it is an ex
extremely potent
and also dangerous psychoactive plant
that has been used
by many different civilizations it's
everywhere
and people die every year from trying to
ingest it
or ingesting it i should say more
accurately so what were some of the
points you hoped to underscore
in the closing portions of
this section right because it's it's not
toxicity clearly
that it's determined no if you go
through it you can find it
there's no rational reason i mean if
you're if you're worried about drugs as
addictiveness
then cigarettes should be illegal
nicotine should be illegal and
caffeine should be illegal highly
addictive substances
that you know people fairly quickly
become dependent on
if your concern is about toxicity yes
you look at things like detoura
if your concern is just public health in
general you look at alcohol
you know alcohol and tobacco are much
more dangerous than any of the drugs
we've criminalized
now we realize it was a folly to
criminalize
alcohol doesn't work as it hasn't worked
with
drugs i mean in general
you know the war on drugs is won by the
drugs they keep flourishing
telling people you can't have them does
not stop it just makes them more
dangerous i mean your friend who died of
a fentanyl
overdose i don't know the details but
that's probably a product of the drug
war because
there's no regulation of what's in
street heroin
and also a lot of people die from
fentanyl overdoses because
often after they've broken their
addiction if people go through
withdrawal
and then slip and they don't realize
that their tolerance has changed
dramatically
they're back to baseline where the drug
has a much bigger effect than it does
after you're addicted so there are many
people
have fentanyl overdoses for that reason
but
point is it's about information and it's
about regulation
and an illegal drug market is going to
lead to lots of
accidental deaths i mean this happened
during prohibition you know people died
from bad hooch
all the time and in fact the government
would put methanol
in various over-the-counter i forget
where they were putting it but they were
using methanol
to contaminate sources of alcohol so
people wouldn't drink them
and they did drink them and so the idea
that a drug war contributes to public
health and
then you have dirty needles and the
spread of aids it doesn't contribute to
public health it has the opposite effect
but there are lots of examples of why is
this legal and why
isn't that and in the end it comes back
to
i mean i tell the story in the piece of
the person
that lived on my land before i bought it
it was a farmer named joe matchus
and he was known there were old apple
trees on the property
these wonderful cider apple trees and he
made hard cider during prohibition and
he was known for having the best apple
jack
apple jack is basically hard cider that
you freeze to get the alcohol
fraction and remove it he made the best
apple jack in town
but this was a crime and he was
committing it on his
property not hurting anybody but
potentially himself
and in those years when he was making
applejack opium was legal and it was in
patent medicines
all over america and in fact we have
evidence
that the women's christian temperance
union and
and those women who were fighting
alcohol were consuming
opium because they would use these
patent medicines and cannabis which
was also in patent medicines so it was a
complete reversal of the current
situation where
alcohol is legal and opium and cannabis
were illegal
so i i wanted to just highlight it's not
totally arbitrary you're right to catch
yourself there
in that we tend to criminalize the drugs
used by
populations that make the establishment
uncomfortable
immigrants and and the poor and
african-americans
but in terms of the schedule too i mean
what's you know i mean
cannabis is still on schedule one
and so are psychedelics this means that
a drug has no
accepted medical use and a high
potential for
abuse neither is true we've demonstrated
the medical utility of psychedelics
and to a lesser extent actually the
medical utility of
cannabis and neither are addictive yet
there they are
so this schedule is an artifact of
politics
no public health authorities would agree
with that schedule
and opiates are two or three schedule
two or three because they do have a
legitimate medical use
and we should remember even in the midst
of the opiate crisis
what a blessing opiates are
morphine surgery would not be bearable
without opiates
and the passage from this life would be
much more painful for people
without morphine so this is you know
like a lot of drugs
opiates are a blessing and a curse and
we need to be able to hold both those
ideas in our head at the same time
as the greeks did you know they called
drugs pharmacon
and that meant literally you know it was
they were both a blessing and a curse
depending on how that how they were used
a poison and an ally
i definitely want to continue with the
discussion
or i should say the segway of sorts from
opium
to seems like our morning favorite for
both of us right now 137
trimethylxanthine
otherwise known as caffeine makes a
little
little less biochemical sounding but
before we get there i just have to say
how much i admire
how to change your mind your previous
book has contributed to
the national and international
conversations
about psychedelics and so i i know
that you've probably heard that before
but i want to say it here because
things do change and conversations
change and just as
populations have been targeted for
persecution
sympathetic populations can be targeted
for treatment
right so in the case of say mdma
assisted psychotherapy
or psilocybin you might have those
suffering from complex ptsd like
veterans or victims of sexual abuse in
the former
or for the latter psilocybin you might
have end of life
sort of existential distress and cancer
patients and so on
and the conversation has dramatically
changed in the last
few years and just yesterday i think
there was a news piece that came out
covering i want to give
him credit where credit is due francis
collins director of the
national institutes of health that's the
nih expressed positive remarks about the
therapeutic potential of psychedelics
and this was in a public discussion
for that to have happened this week
would have been to my mind i don't want
to say unimaginable but
things are happening a lot faster than
even i
would have expected so it's it's so i
think
instructive to study the history to see
how
quickly things can change or how
dramatically things can change because
like you said the the women's
christian temperance union would relax
with their women's tonics with loudoun
opium uh after it to take the edge off
after a hard day of fighting alcohol
so i just wanted to give you a pat on
the back for really contributing to
a deeper more nuanced conversation of
psychedelics
specifically thank you you know it has
been remarkable what we've seen in the
last three years
and you know i'm sure the book played a
role but also the research
you know the research is panning out
when i wrote that book a lot of it
hadn't been published yet i i knew
from talking to the researchers what was
coming and the publications have done a
lot to
move the conversation along because we
have some very good
evidence that these work for the various
indications you're talking about and
we'll have evidence of
other indications it's valued other
indications too
but culture does change and it can
change
really quickly i used to write a lot
about food and agriculture and
and that conversation you know changed
and
you know there a lot of people who give
me credit in both cases
which is very nice but as journalists
you know i think we are we kind of have
a
if we have any talent it's that we have
a sense of where the culture is moving
and that the the culture might be ready
to hear this
and i had a um a mentor in publishing
many years ago
who said that as journalists you you
know the goal is to be a short-term
visionary
if you're a long-term visionary no one
will know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
and you will not sell any books or
articles but you want to just see around
one corner
and i've always kept that in mind but i
have to say that
with regards to psychedelics it's
happened much faster than i imagined
i just see any opposition kind of
melting away and
that i didn't expect i expected a lot of
pushback when
when how to change your mind came out
from the you know psychiatric
establishment
and from mainstream media because there
was so much baggage surrounding
psychedelics in our culture going back
to you know
the 1960s but there wasn't and and
that's
that i think is really interesting and
the reason there wasn't and i didn't
understand this until later
i think we talked about this last time
is that mental health care
is in crisis the people who practice it
the psychiatrists and the therapists and
psychologists
know that they don't have very good
tools they have no tools
that cure anything at the best they can
alleviate symptoms
but the drugs they have to alleviate
symptoms are pretty lousy
and people don't like taking them and
they uh they're addictive in effect
you can't get off ssris very easily
and people put on weight and they lose
their sex drive and and it's a you know
the tools are lousy and so the prospect
of acquiring new tools
to deal with a growing mental health
crisis
is attractive to just about everyone
there is at least curiosity and openness
and in many other cases support so i
think it's a measure of desperation
as much as anything and then the media
too has been so friendly i mean there
was a cover story in the times two weeks
ago
three weeks ago that how psychedelics
are going to revolutionize psychiatry
and that's probably what francis collins
is responding to and that has to do and
that piece was inspired by
the phase 3 mdma trial that maps brought
out as well as
robin carhart harris's depression trial
psychedelic research used to end up in
in journals you've never heard about i
mean that first study that
that hopkins at nyu did about
existential distress was in the journal
of neuropharmacology or something or
psychopharmacology
you know pretty small journal based in
england
now they're in you know new england
journal of medicine uh robin's last
depression study
and the map study was in what was it
nature
medicine or nature psychiatry i forget
one of the one of the nature
yeah umbrella journals so now this
research is in the
the top tier journals and so the the
respectability the other measure
of of acceptance that has really struck
me is
all these universities starting
psychedelic research centers
that harvard is starting one at mass
general i took as particularly
surprising
i remember a few years ago having lunch
with a young
psychiatrist at mgh who was fascinated
by uh
psychedelics and and we had lunch and
and he was very eager to start something
in harvard
and i said well i'm afraid harvard's
going to be the last place to do this
because of the timothy leary you know
embarrassment as they as
as the harvard people think of it but i
was wrong they're doing it too
and they've got a very interesting
center getting started so and yale has a
center and now berkeley has a center
that i'm involved with
and the stigma is washing off
it's wonderful to see it is it's really
exciting
and i think the the curve of change
sort of the the angle of that inflection
is just
going to continue to point skyward by
all indications certainly with the
for-profit
and it's it's important for people to
keep that in mind when you know we get
discouraged about politics and change
all the time and the model that has
always struck me is gay marriage i mean
that
how that went from in the course of just
the obama administration
from something that a national
politician couldn't touch
to one that he had to touch and the
culture changed around gay marriage
so quickly so we should you know take
heart in the fact that
when you tell the story in the right way
when you have good research
because the gay marriage story was like
oh these people
want what we have not they want to
be different they want this basic
human institution called marriage and
that tells a very different story
about homosexuality than was in a lot of
people's heads it was it was a brilliant
thing to focus on it seemed crazy at the
time
i know a lot of activists thought that
was a risky move and
asking for the sky but it wasn't it was
exactly the right move
as was the move of starting with cancer
patients
uh roland griffiths and the team at nyu
we're going to use psychedelics to help
people who are dying how can you be
against that
and the fact that it worked opened up
this research into depression and
anxiety and obsession
and because they were telling a really
good story and
all i did was amplify that story and
find a way to talk about it that made it
much more sympathetic i think than it
was i mean most of the people writing
about psychedelics before i did it
were you know in the tank already right
they were sold on psychedelics they were
users of psychedelics they were
believers and those are not the people
you want to tell your story
ever
and i was skeptical and i had one foot
out and one foot in i was terrified of
using psychedelics before i started i
hadn't used them at the age appropriate
time
so in some ways i was the right
messenger because i i was more like
the average reader than most people who
would write about psychedelics and and
that
you know finding as a writer finding
where you stand
who you are in the story you're telling
is everything
in terms of getting people to to come
with you on the journey
yeah the uh those steeped in the
kool-aid can always
be a be a liability i remember
yeah they're kind of off-putting yeah no
one likes
no one likes evangelists except the
people who do
well i remember after my first book came
out and i was just becoming too
engaged more publicly and someone said
to me i wish i could remember who it was
but they said you know
it's not the detractors you need to
worry about it's the die hard fans who
get the message
who get the message wrong and i was like
oh i don't know what that means but it
didn't take long to realize
how true yeah how true that is so let's
let's talk about mescaline i think
that's probably the most
natural segue from what we're talking
about right now
you i suppose gave some preview of this
already but
what makes mescaline interesting what
makes it different from
say psilocybin or lsd yeah from any
context
well it has a different phenomenology as
the philosophers say
the experience has a very different
quality and i was very surprised
to discover that i had read aldous
huxley's dorsal perception
when i was working on how to change your
mind and before i had used a psychedelic
it's a wonderful essay i encourage
everybody to look at it it's the first
trip report really
and and it's influenced everybody's trip
since then
you may not have read this book but what
you saw and happened to you
on psychedelics he wrote in part because
that's the way culture works
because we're looking for vocabulary and
names for what's happening to us and we
take them from literature
even indirectly anyway when i read that
i thought
it was an account of the er psychedelic
experience
you know that this stood for lsd
experience it stood for psilocybin
experience
and that's how i took it and a lot of
people take it that way
but then i read it again after i had
used you know gone through the menu of
psychedelics in my
research and i realized oh this is very
specific
this is not like lsd or psilocybin in
this quality
the masculine experience as described by
him and
and i can confirm this based on my own
experience although my own experience
was probably influenced by him
it doesn't take you out of this world to
another world
as people say talk about dmt you know
taking you to another dimension of
existence or
it takes you deeper into this world
huxley describes being able to stare at
the folds of his trousers for an
hour and it made him think about folds
of cloth and botticelli's paintings
and it just makes the present
richer and deeper and you know he uses
this metaphor the reducing valve
that he he argues that most of
consciousness is editing
reality keeping things from us because
we would be overwhelmed if we took in
all the sensory information available to
us at any one time
we just couldn't process it well on
mescaline those valves open really wide
and the sensory information is so
intense
the colors are you just see nuances of
green or blue in in nature or blue in
the water that you've never seen before
and you can stare at the most common
object
and find it absolutely fascinating and
understand it in a deeper way
there was no ego dissolution there were
no hallucinations really
it's this here and now drug in a way i
wasn't prepared for
so it has different quality also you can
hold a conversation much more easily
you're not
chemically mescaline is closer to mdma
than it is to lsd it's phenylethymine
so it has that kind of warmth and
sometimes chattiness
and heart opening quality that mdma has
compared to as i think of psilocybin and
lsd is a very solitary
endeavor you know somewhere you're going
deep into your head
so it had a very different quality an
interesting question is so why
isn't it used in research and this
points to another difference
it is a very long trip it can be like 14
hours longer than lsd
and if you're really enjoying it it is
the most generous of
psychedelics if you're getting a little
tired and you'd like to go to bed or
have dinner
it's like can we stop this now is this
enough
and i think that makes it very hard in a
research context where you need a
therapist present
and you know 14 hours is two shifts
right for the uh for the therapist
so it hasn't been used although there
are plans to use it
in therapy and i think it has potential
i think it has particular potential in
group therapy
since there is this ability to talk and
that you might be able to administer in
a group which would
help but i also think
the reason i was interested in mescaline
2 is its long history of use in the
native american community
first of all it is the oldest known
psychedelic in use i mean there is
evidence 6 000
years ago in texas they found evidence
of
of mescaline use in the form of peyote
the peyote cactus
and peyote has been used by natives in
both
mexico and the united states for a very
long time
and they've had great success treating
trauma with it treating alcoholism with
it
and so i think there's a great deal to
learn i was fascinated by
the native american use of mescaline in
the form of peyote
here we have a essentially a
conservative model
of drug use and that kind of blows our
minds because we think of
you know especially psychedelics we
think of disruption of society certainly
in the 60s
so the native american church which is
developed in the 1880s and kind of
made official in 1917 is the
container the cultural container that
native americans
develop for the use of peyote and it's a
highly
regulated ritual that is used
in what are called peyote meetings to
help people
in trouble especially with alcoholism
which has been a huge problem for native
american cultures since it was
introduced
but also for spousal abuse as a right of
passage
to help people deal with trauma and to
help native americans deal with their
trauma i mean this is
you know a very this is a traumatized
population and it was particularly
traumatized in the 1880s
this is when plains indians were being
forced onto reservations
people who had lived itinerant lives in
many cases
following the buffalo or the bison and
suddenly they were
forced onto reservations and given
rations of corn
they didn't know about corn these
weren't agriculturalists so they fed it
to their horses i mean
imagine how traumatized such a
population would be
and in the 1880s native americans from
texas brought peyote into
oklahoma where where the that was the
indian territory where a lot of the
reservations were
and they began using it in a ritual
setting and it was
they found it enormously helpful and
they still find it enormously helpful
so there's a very interesting a moral
conservative use
of a drug to hold a society together to
create cultural cohesion and healing and
it has a lot to teach us
and why mescaline was the right
substance for that is an interesting
question
so i wanted to explore that and
it raised a very hard question for me
though which is whether i should
use peyote whether any non-native person
should use peyote
because it's in very short supply the
habitat which is
runs along the rio grande on the texas
side there's a lot more of it on the
mexican side
but you know between cattle ranching and
development and poaching
by you know psychonauts and it's a very
slow growing plant it takes 15 years to
get from seed to usable button
it's a low growing very pretty bluish
green cactus
it looks like a stone or a pin cushion
and you actually eat it
you eat the whole thing but there is uh
a real question about
you know i mean we have taken so much
from these people
that if we now take their peyote which
has been such an important
aid to them adjusting to the situation
we've
put them in i think there's a real moral
and ethical question about that i mean
it'd be one thing to grow your own
peyote i and i wouldn't have a problem
with that
but see me in 15 years and it'll be
ready
and this is of course been become a
controversy because there's a
decriminalized nature movement that's
very vibrant in america right now
and the idea of leaving out peyote is is
offensive to some people in that
movement it kind of complicates their
message which is that all these
psychoactive plants should be
legal and available to people so there's
a there's now a fight between the native
american church and decrim nature going
on
which is really unfortunate my basic
thinking is we should leave this one
alone
and the way you the way you pay respects
both to peyote and to native americans
is not to use their sacrament
and there are other ways to get
mescaline you don't have to use their
sacrament
there's san pedro for example which is
another cactus
that comes from from south america and
is very easy to grow
and once i had my eyes on to notice it
and knew what it would look like i see
it all over berkeley where i live
and i bet it's all over austin too
it's all over the place everywhere i
remember uh first becoming familiar with
its
look and i noticed in san francisco in a
sort of empty space between two
apartments across the street from where
i lived
a bunch of san pedro cactus yeah and
it's
it it thrives so like you said and and
i'll just
second your position which is i think
there's a lot
of good being done by the decrim nature
movements in various places and
i think that that good can exist
while reserving peyote for indigenous
use
and having looked at this quite closely
and spent time
as you have with ipci the indigenous
peyote conservation initiative which i
encourage people to check out
ipci yeah really important initiative
and having spoken with
members of the nac as you have and
others
leaders in the dna or navajo communities
like steve benally the availability of
peyote is such
that if we continue at current rates of
consumption
also recognizing that for indigenous
northern american and indigenous people
greenhouse grown
or hydroponic grown peyote is not viewed
in the same way as a sacrament
necessarily as something grown on the
ground which takes 15 years
and there are other
means by which one can get mescaline a
san pedro cactus being
one one good option so and it is legal
by the way it's legal to grow
san pedro cactus yeah and it's not legal
to grow peyote so
it's that's another advantage to saying
a lot of benefits a lot of benefits so
what did you do
well i had hoped so this chapter is very
much uh
all three sections of this book have
there's a writing problem it's
interesting or a publishing problem
um you know with opium i it looks like
i'm not gonna be able to publish and i
have to self-censor
with uh caffeine i abstain from caffeine
to the point where i can't write
and and the very the very chapter is
endangered by the lack of the
of the drug and in uh mescaline
there was the pandemic and i was looking
forward to
going to texas and participating in a
peyote ceremony before i understood
these issues
and meeting all these native americans
in person and interviewing native
americans on zoom is not always easy
because
they don't have good internet
connections on the reservation and
sometimes they have
to drive for hours to get to a good
internet connection so they can talk to
you
so it was a piece that was inflected by
that but i did
talk to quite a few native americans and
i was really struck by first their
reluctance to tell me what happens in
the tent
how has this helped you and it was a
real wake-up call to me i mean these are
normal journalistic questions you would
ask anybody
and i remember steve benelli who you
just mentioned saying you know
why should i tell you and
white man the unspoken next thing and he
said you know
we have a long history of discoverers
like you
coming to our world and taking things i
was just
you know kind of shocked but of course
yeah why
why should he and ultimately i found
people who would describe what happened
in the tent
and and the value to their people i
learned a lot
in the course of doing that and it was
very humbling in a way so
i grew uh san pedro and i was
lucky to get some really good specimens
from the shulgin farm
ann and sasha shulgin they have a
wonderful sasha shogun was fascinated by
peyote cactus and san pedro and he was
always tweaking the mescaline molecule
that was his
his favorite one to mess with and then
i've some other friends in berkeley gave
me some and i you know they're very easy
to
to take cuttings and the plant just
wants to grow
you can just take a length of it if one
falls
you know and they fall over in storms
and and leave it anywhere and it'll send
up
new columns uh it's remarkable but it's
important for your listeners to know
that at a certain moment it does become
a very serious crime when you cook your
san pedro
so growing it's fine it's not scheduled
as a plan
but if you prepare it and it's prepared
essentially like a vegetable stock
you are breaking federal law
you've crossed has crossed the line
across the line
has anyone been arrested for this i
don't think the authorities really know
about san pedro otherwise they would
have scheduled it
i think it just kind of got lost in the
wash and
i think it would be hard to get in
trouble
using san pedro it's it's a fairly mild
psychedelic well i don't want to give
bad advice
you could get in lots of trouble i don't
want to be responsible how far we've
come from the
fear and loathing in connecticut michael
well we are in a different moment and
and and mescaline for the masses here we
go
the drug war is subsiding it's fading i
mean you know what happened in the
the last election i think was really
significant you had
oregon decriminalizing all drugs
specifically legalizing
psilocybin therapy you had several
states including red states
legalizing cannabis and you had decrim
ballot initiative passed in washington
dc
and several other places so something is
changing
and the right doesn't even want to fight
the drug war but
i would argue and and this book in a way
one of the subtexts of this book is
when the drug war ends our confusion and
problems around drugs are not going to
end
in fact they're going to intensify
because you know it's one thing to have
the government
take charge of you can use this you
can't use this and law abiding people
follow that or not
but each of these drugs we have to
figure out our relationship to them
drug abuse is is is a dysfunctional
relationship with drugs
in my view so what's the proper
container for mescaline what's the
proper container for caffeine
what's the proper container for alcohol
you know we've kind of worked out
this truce with alcohol and cigarettes
it's not perfect
but we know prohibition doesn't work so
we have all these social rules that
govern the use of
alcohol and we've sort of de-socialized
the use of tobacco
you know only in the last 20 years right
you you can't use it in all these places
where you once could
there's a stigma now attached to smoking
in lots of places which i think is a
healthy thing
but the point is it's going to be
culture rather than the law
that is i think going to shape this and
that conversation is going to take place
over the next couple decades and it's
going to be fascinating
so the question is after the drug war
what does the drug peace look like
that's where we are now we have to
figure that out and we're kind of
working on it with psychedelics
we know there's going to be this fda
approval
you know this medicine path but there's
also
this religious path there are already
some psychedelic churches and they're
going to be a lot more and they're going
to be tested in the courts
bob jesse's idea the betterment of well
people i mean
how do we make it available what's the
container for people who are neither
religious or sick that conversation is
happening right now it's very exciting
and it will happen i think around
opiates also there's a real difference
between making some opium
tea because you've got a bad back or
you're sad
and you know using fentanyl or shooting
up there's a whole
spectrum of ways to use drugs going back
to that idea that
fundamental paradox of blessing and
curse
ally and poison we always have to keep
that in mind and navigate that path
because all drugs can get you in trouble
oh yeah
it's uh you know paracelsus the dose
makes the poison certainly applies in
many cases and i was i was talking to
an acquaintance of a new friend recently
at a dinner
and the topic of
the well the topic of drug regulation
and drug development came up
and he mentioned that he he grew up
somewhat religious
and had never used any drugs except for
alcohol and i said oh you mean the
civilization destroyer
that just that one uh and of course i
was joking and
you know we had a laugh but it's
tremendous how
and i don't expect legislation to change
around i'll call anytime soon but
but but how how much the cultural
context can shift
the lens through which we look at these
things and mescaline is very
interesting for a bunch of reasons and
it's also
at least at a basic level kind of self
limiting in the sense that not only does
it last
as it stands right now let's just say up
to 12 or 14 hours
but a very common side effect is feeling
extremely nauseous
uh so so if one might imagine the most
intense seasickness they've ever felt
you may feel that for six to 12 hours
and uh of course i think in the
therapeutic and this is on synthetic
synthetic mescaline or cactus or or on
plant derived
and it's sometimes referred to in
the communities that use peyote as
getting well if you vomit that's getting
well not getting
not getting sick and while i think
in that container that is accepted from
a psychotherapeutic
perspective poses some challenges i do
think you could probably take zofran or
some anti-nausea medication
to attenuate it but do you think
at least based on your reading and
research that
there are potential applications outside
of
say alcoholism and addiction and as you
mentioned and i think it's worth
underscoring part of what is
i think attractive about mescaline is
that
it does not easily
fall it does not obviously fall into the
class of hallucinogen i know there are
people who will
who disagree with this because at high
enough doses certainly you can
you can experience visuals but it
doesn't produce
the type of experience that you
mentioned these tryptamines often
involve where you're sent to
a parallel dimension where you're riding
mechanical elves i mean that is
less the experience than a sort of
heightening of reality in your sensory
inputs
so i think it could end up being viewed
very much the way that mdma is
is viewed yeah do you think there are
any particular targets or
indications for which mescaline or maybe
some designer version of mesclun
would be interesting alcoholism is the
obvious one because that's been
where it's had a lot of success in the
native american community
although they use it you know they use
it for physical healing too i mean they
really think it's helpful with various
physical
and and their stories of you know that i
did hear from native americans about
children being cured of cancer and
physical ailments
i think we know a lot less about it and
i think that
we need some really basic research into
mescaline that hasn't been done yet
and that goes for other substances too i
mean the the focus has been so narrowly
on psilocybin
and mdma and there are good reasons for
that but substances like mescaline have
been neglected
and you know journey collab is a new
startup that is
hopes to work with mescaline and and has
a very uh elaborate system of
reciprocity with native americans that a
certain amount of their revenue is going
to go to native american communities
and there is a researcher university of
alabama who wants to use
mesclun but in his case it's going to be
alcoholism i think that'll be the first
indication
i'm not sure what else would be good but
i would guess trauma
would be worth looking at i mean mdma
has already proven its value there so i
don't know whether there'll be a lot of
people willing to invest the resources
necessary
but trauma is what it's the mdma
qualities of it
you know suggest that and the fact that
it's been used by native americans so
successfully
uh and in effect they are dealing with
trauma in one form or another
one symptom or another but this raises a
very interesting question whether
jump ahead 50 years and psychedelic
therapy
is a thing it's just part of mental
health treatment
will it be the familiar molecules
you know that have been around for a
while mescaline psilocybin dmt
or will there be drugs we haven't we
can't imagine right now
tweaked versions and now there's a whole
lot of that drug development going on
driven in part by desire to control
patents right intellectual property
but all these companies even the ones
that are you know working with
psilocybin they're tweaking psilocybin
too trying to come up with something
shorter acting perhaps or without
certain side effects
and then you have the development of all
these non-psychoactive
psychedelics which to me just seems kind
of nuts but
for a lot of people that may be the way
to go and there you know there's a whole
effort to prove and there's some
evidence it might work on certain
indications that a psychedelic
that didn't produce any phenomenological
effects
could nevertheless be a healing
substance and that is very attractive to
the pharmaceutical industry
to large portions of the population it
flies in the face of the
general belief that it is the nature of
the experience you have
that's curing you not anything
pharmacological
and that question will be resolved in
the next few years and i understand that
roland griffith made a bet
with somebody who wanted to test this
concept by giving a a big dose of
psychedelics to someone
anesthetized like really deeply
anesthetized to see if
this would actually affect him and
roland was willing to bet that
it would not that you have to have the
experience
but we are learning that there is a
pharmacological effect in terms of
neurogenesis
and uh and brain plasticity so who knows
so we may look back on words like
mescaline and psilocybin as like ancient
history
in 50 years when we have all these new
substances or not
you know sasha shulkin developed lots of
new substances and
we're still very interested in the
originals yeah what do you think about
that
well i think that and just as a side
note for for anyone who's
has some passing familiarity with
anything in the 2c
x class so 2cb if you've ever heard of
something like 2cb or 2ce
which is a much trickier substance
to use that can produce some very
dramatic unraveling so i don't
necessarily recommend but
2cb would be one of sasha's in a sense
one of his molecules
absolutely so i think that if i look at
the market forces and incentives of
for-profit companies much like we have
ketamine regularly available and at very
low cost
nonetheless we now have s ketamine and
bravado
through i think i want to say johnson
and johnson i may be getting
the pharma company wrong for ongoing
administration
so i think that we will see pressure
a lot of pressure by shareholders by
founders
by incentives alone which then shape
behavior and decisions
towards non-psychedelic
versions of psychedelics or close
cousins
that require constant administration
rather
than so rather than conferring
potential curative effects in a handful
of sessions using it
more to mask symptoms or suppress
symptoms
for better business models i don't want
to sound
cynical but i do think that if we study
our history
this is what we see over and over and
over and over again
and i think the playbooks that have been
used by
big pharma big tobacco are going to be
used in this world as well
we already see that in fact we see a lot
of the same
tactics and strategies being used which
are not necessarily
the best for the scientific therapeutic
innovation
within the ecosystem but that is
for better and for worse uh often for
worse but not always
how the free market game is played
uh and i and i i do think that the
the comments made by uh francis collins
are a very
big deal and hopefully a harbinger of
things to come
because right now and i'd love to hear
your opinion on this but
researchers find themselves in sometimes
in between a rock and a hard place with
respect to funding because they can
either pursue
individual philanthropists who
take time to wrangle often don't have a
lot of budget
and the fundraising then becomes a
part-time
full-time job for these researchers or
they can take money
from for-profit players
which as you would expect have something
to gain in the forms of strings attached
and that could be ip ownership it could
be
exclusive access to safety data it could
be
non-compete clauses or non-disclosure
clauses that act in some way as
non-compete
i've seen some really really bad
behaviors so
my hope would be that if that happens
which i think is
is more of an eventuality so it's a
matter of trying to put safeguards in
place
or allowing people in different
positions to act
as countervailing forces whether that's
from a law advocacy perspective or from
a journalistic perspective let's just
say my hope would be that
through the efforts of groups and
movements like decrim nature that
at the very least the other better known
versions that we've been referring to
so let's just say san pedro cactus
silasi mushrooms etc
remain available for use
or legal on some level to use
that would be my hope how does any of
that yeah land for you
that jibes i mean i think we're at an
inflection point and a huge amount of
capital has moved into this space
and very quickly and that the desire to
figure out ways to
take psychedelics and force them into
this model of the pill you have to take
every day
the pill that isn't disruptive the pill
that doesn't take any talking therapy
is going to be fierce and as will the
desire to
make original intellectual property
nature will save us though the
philosophy mushrooms will continue to
grow
the mescaline producing cactuses will
continue to grow
and that as the drug war ends people's
access
their ability to do it themselves that's
not going to go away
however compass pathways thinks it can
control
psilocybin through ip psilocybin
will defeat that i think maybe not in
the business context or the
pharmaceutical context
but in reality so i think that you know
nature is irrepressible
and i don't think these substances will
go away you mentioned
uh for your harper's piece way back in
the day that
rick mcarthur so strongly supported
that you worked on it for a year right
that's a long time so
i know it's crazy and that you were
counting on that paycheck right you i
don't know if you had mortgage payments
at the time but
it was i did it was important to your
your livelihood and also therefore a
determinant of your ability to continue
writing that you had that kind of
support do you want to maybe this is as
good a time as any to mention
the fellowship do you want to introduce
this
yeah yeah so as i've continued to stay
involved in this area
i'm doing it in different ways and as
are you and
i was involved with the founding of a
psychedelic research center at berkeley
that just got established last year and
we're doing a couple things that we
thought would be different than other
centers
but that would also help the entire
field
so rather than doing clinical research
which isn't done at berkeley because we
don't have a medical school
we're going to do basic science we're
really going to try to understand the
brain mechanisms involved in psychedelic
experience
and explore what psychedelics have to
teach us about things like consciousness
and predictive coding and
perception we're also going to do
training of guides which is
understood to be the great bottleneck
going forward i think maps
or the funders collaborative estimates
we're going to need a hundred thousand
guides in the next 10 years
and then the third thing that i'm most
excited about because i'm going to be
directly involved and i have something
to contribute is we're going to do a
major public education initiative
there's a huge amount of curiosity about
psychedelics and
sources of information are somewhat
limited and
not always that rigorous so i see
psychedelics
as becoming a very important
journalistic beat in the next 10 or 20
years
in the same way food and agriculture
became an important beat
beginning in the early 2000s before then
just to use that as a model
journalism about food was essentially
the recipe page you know the the pages
on wednesday in the newspaper
and journalism about agriculture was
trade magazines you know like beef
today or progressive grocer that's where
you had to go to learn what was
happening in
agriculture beginning with eric
schlosser's
you know important book fast food nation
in 2002
and a couple other books including my
omnivore's dilemma
in 2006 suddenly writing about food and
agriculture as a unified whole
as a system took off and now you have a
generation of journalists who are
good at it and cover the subject well
and and you can learn a lot about where
your food comes from and its carbon
footprint and all this kind of
information is out there
so we need to do the same for
psychedelics
it's a rich beat it involves many layers
there is science there is policy there
is business
and there is culture and we don't have a
lot of people writing about it yet
so how do we attract really talented
young journalists to work on it
and that will serve everybody and so we
came up with a series of ideas
one of which you and i discussed which
was
what if we created a journalism
fellowship
where we would have a sum of money each
year to give
grants to young journalists who have
cool ideas to report on
psychedelics whether it's business or
science or culture or whatever
and you very generously funded it it
will be called the
ferris uc berkeley journalism fellowship
i think it is
we're going to assemble a small panel of
judges with expertise in science policy
and
business and every year we'll give out
grants to people
and help fund their journalism whether
they need five thousand or ten thousand
or fifteen thousand dollars
and i know for young journalists this
can make all the difference
and that they then can take these pieces
and pitch them to magazines mainstream
magazines so i'm hoping it'll bring more
psychedelic journalism into mainstream
magazines
some of which don't have resources to
fund expensive
reporting there's been a change in
journalism where
journalism that's been supported by
non-profit
organizations can appear in places like
the new york times magazine
or or the atlantic or harpers
that they're willing to take funded
journalism as long as they believe that
the source is credible and the fact that
the
uc berkeley journalism school graduate
school of journalism will be the
container for this for the ferris
fellowship
i think we'll give our journalists a
real leg up in terms of getting
published
so that's probably going to launch in
the fall we'll start taking
applications and on a rolling basis so
anyway if you're
if you're a journalist with a really
good idea i hope you'll get in touch
with us and we'll we'll publicize it
you know how to do it if you follow my
twitter feed we'll definitely have it
there
and perhaps in tim's newsletter as well
so anyway i
i'm very grateful for tim to tim for
recognizing
you know the value of this we're also
hoping to do some other things
we're going to do a newsletter starting
this summer that will be free
and we'll have a digestive news about
psychedelics about the field
i've just hired a young science writer
to to do that i think she's going to be
terrific
and it'll report on new research as well
as other developments
eventually we hope to do a podcast and
we're going to do a massive online
course too
psychedelic science 101 that i'm working
with my colleagues to develop so
i'm hoping that berkeley will become a
center for you know really
high quality journalism related to
psychedelics
we all at the center are very grateful
to uh to you tim for
for supporting this effort well i've i
couldn't be more
excited i have watched this
field so so closely over the years
most recent years and couldn't think of
a better person
to head it up and also not sure if
if you touched on this or if we touched
on it perhaps earlier but you have
sort of experimental data so to speak
this is not the first time that you've
offered these types of grants so i would
love to
yeah maybe hear about uh how
your experiments in other subject areas
have turned out because it will be this
isn't the first rodeo
in other words no actually about
eight years ago i started a similar
fellowship
which is the 11th hour wendy schmitz
foundation 11th hour
berkeley journalism fellowships and this
was to cover
food and agriculture and it's organized
somewhat differently
we take 10 people a year they we get
several hundred applications people who
have an idea
young journalists you know 30s early 30s
or 20s
and we picked 10 and we give them
a ten thousand dollar grant to report
their stories
and we also give them help in shaping
those stories pitching them
and helping them with the editing and
introducing them to editors
some of which we'll do with this grant
it's not going to be quite as hands-on
because
i think these people are going to be in
a slightly different stage in their
career
but we found that this was incredibly
helpful to people's careers
i'll give you one example there was a
young journalist
named nikola twilly who had a really
cool idea about
the refrigeration revolution coming to
china
a country without good refrigeration is
only going to develop
to a certain level and refrigeration has
all sorts of implications for the food
system and climate change all
kinds of things and she had this cool
idea about going to china as they're
at the embarking on this revolution and
she
wrote a really good pitch and she sent
it to the new york times magazine and
they said well
this is a great story but you know you
don't have any experience
reporting from china or you know we
can't afford to send you
if you were a name writer or whatever we
would
so she came to us and we gave her a
grant and she went back to the times
and she said well what if i can cover
all my expenses
and they said great we'll take your
piece they took her piece they published
it it was very successful
and it led to a book which is coming out
i think next year
she also met someone else in that
fellowship and they started a very good
podcast
whose name i'm forgetting we put it in
the show notes also
okay i'll send it to you anyway so it's
you know and now she's a new yorker
staff writer
and uh wow so you know and she still
writes a lot about food
the right boost at the right moment in
someone's career can make
such a difference so we're hoping this
is you know we're gonna build a cadre of
of really good journalists who have the
necessary skills and skepticism
and investigative abilities to
hold this space accountable because
we're moving from a time where the
scientists have held the microphone
about psychedelic research to a moment
where the entrepreneurs are going to
hold the microphone
and as you pointed out they've got a
very different agenda
and there's some cool ideas coming and
there's some really bad ideas coming
and one of the ways you hold an industry
accountable is with good journalism
and we saw that with food that led to
real changes
in the food system so we we're going to
need the same in psychedelics
it's going to get much more contentious
and much more complicated in the years
to come
so we're hoping that we'll have a group
of journalists up to the task of
holding everybody's feet to the fire
couldn't be coming at a better time
i am i'm so excited about this michael
there are two more things
i'd love to touch on one is related to
the book
and one is gonna bring us full circle in
a way
i'm holding up my mug for those who
can't see it all right
all right coffee so as we all know
it has always been the case that the
brits drink tea
and americans just love their coffee
what is that a true statement
yeah uh yeah it is i mean they're
definitely a tea culture and we're more
of a coffee culture and there's a
specific historical reason for it
i do see coffee now getting when you're
in london now you're very aware of
coffee
and there's a lot of great coffee houses
but initially
when coffee and tea were first
introduced to europe
which happens in the same decade in the
1650s
it was coffee that took off and coffee
became this tremendous fad in england
and there were coffee houses there was
one coffee house for every 150
londoners i mean they were everywhere
and people were spending
hours and hours in the coffee house
which became much more than a place to
drink coffee it became
really a social media you would go to
the coffee house to get the news
it was about information more than it
was about the drug although the drug
definitely played its role and there
were different coffee houses for
whatever your interest was so if you
were an artist
you would go to this one in covent
garden and if you were a scientist there
was one associated with
the royal institution the great
scientific institution in london
and if you were in business you might go
to lloyds which became lloyds of london
because you could actually write a
policy on your ship and your cargo there
and then people would go from one to the
other conveying news so
it was initially a coffee culture but
the english colonies weren't good places
to grow coffee they didn't have any
coffee growing colonies
they had tea growing colonies like india
and they had a foothold in china
so beginning about a hundred years later
tea became so much cheaper and tea took
over
from coffee by and large and it was just
about colonial politics and
the nature of imperialism countries with
good coffee growing colonies like
amsterdam
like the netherlands and like france
they were much more
coffee and when america was started we
were a tea culture because we were
getting all this tea that the british
east india company was
was bringing in but of course with the
revolution
we revolted against all things english
you'll recall the tea party from your
high school
history textbooks and the the tax on t
was so offensive to the colonists that
they threw a whole shipment of tea into
boston harbor
and switched to coffee and we have been
the coffee country ever since
caffeine in general has been very
important to capitalism
in that it makes us better workers makes
us more efficient
so one of the stories i tell in in the
chapter on caffeine is is just how
important
caffeine was to the rise of capitalism
it's important to know
just how drunk everybody was before
caffeine came to europe
people were drinking all day long they
drank for breakfast
they drank for lunch they drank for
dinner there were alcohol breaks
instead of coffee breaks on farms
and this was all fine when you're doing
physical labor
but once you start operating machines
and and you have to deal with double
entry bookkeeping
a drunk workforce is a serious problem
so
enter coffee and caffeine which was
it didn't completely displace alcohol
but it became
it diminished the need for alcohol one
of the reasons people were drinking so
much
was not just to change consciousness but
because alcohol was safer than the water
then
when you ferment you disinfect but
coffee and tea were even safer than that
because you had to boil water it was the
first time
there was any reason to boil water and
so the countries that adopted
hot drinks were much healthier and had
much better public health
so caffeine's this huge boon to the
industrial revolution people who can
safely handle machines and also you
can't
have a night shift without caffeine
right we were stuck with the circadian
rhythms of the
of the rhythms of the sun and only when
caffeine comes along could you extend
the workday
and you know the best proof of this idea
is if you think about it the institution
of the coffee break
is like a what a wild idea your employer
gives you
time off to take a drug and provides the
drug
why do they do that well it was
discovered in
only in like the 1900s that employees
who got coffee breaks
at mid morning and mid afternoon did
more work
perform better and i tell the story of
the company where the first coffee break
was
instituted so caffeine has changed
the course of civilization in many many
ways it really contributed to the rise
of rationalism in europe too
a certain way of thinking that's very
linear
very rational very logical and i
understood this
in part when i got off coffee um
you know the reason i got off coffee was
i i mentioned that challenge from roland
but i also wanted to see if i could
learn reacquaint myself with its power
because if we use it every day
basically it gives us a little lift and
it stops withdrawal
the symptoms of withdrawal which are
really nasty and every morning you know
you're starting to go through withdrawal
till you have that first cup and then
it's like
everything's okay and you get back to
baseline but if you've been off it for a
few months
that first cup is psychedelic
it is it is as powerful as any drug i've
had
and uh it was wonderful and and the the
only sad thing is you can't hold on to
that power
by the by the third day oh no
so anyway i had quite a journey with
caffeine as did our
our civilization but it's a wonderful
substance there are
no good reasons not to consume it
well with one exception i mean i looked
at the whole all the health issues
tied to it now you can abuse caffeine
you can have too much until you're you
know
and anxious people will get more jittery
sometimes
but it's good for your heart it's good
for your blood pressure it prevents
certain kinds of cancer
it's associated with lower rates of
certain kinds of cancer
dementia it improves your memory it
improves people's performance
in athletics it's kind of amazing the
only negative
is it messes with your sleep even if you
stop drinking coffee at noon it has a
quarter life of 12 hours so a quarter of
the caffeine that you ingested will
still
be in your bloodstream at midnight
and what it robs you of or can is deep
sleep
which is very important for our health
so there are some sleep
most of the sleep researchers i
interviewed don't consume caffeine
i was like
[Laughter]
but on balance we should count ourselves
fortunate
and why did this plant produce this
chemical that has this effect on us
well it began as a pesticide it is a
pesticide
not in human brains and
and one way it strikes me that caffeine
has
changed civilization is by fooling us
into thinking or what percentage of us
ninety percent
use it worldwide use it regularly and by
the way it's the only drug we give our
children
if you think about it in the form of
soda it's wild
uh it's convinced ninety percent of
people on the planet
that their baseline their so-called
normal waking consciousness
is actually sober but it's not
it's it's infused with caffeine we are
we are creatures of caffeine now
it's so transparent in its effects it
doesn't feel like you're
high certainly but this way we operate
our ability to focus when i was writing
how to change your mind i learned that
there's these two different kinds of
consciousness there's
lantern consciousness and spotlight
consciousness
lantern consciousness you're taking in
information from all sides it's kind of
a little add-ish
kids have lantern consciousness the
ability to narrow
your focus and block out everything else
is really critical to adult life to work
to scientific discovery to writing books
to so many things that we do
fixing cars that spotlight consciousness
is nurtured by caffeine
and that's a huge gift it's interesting
i asked roland griffith
so is this a boon or a bane to our
species
and he said well it's definitely a boon
to our civilization
because now we have to get up at a
certain time and be somewhere at a
certain time and perform certain
functions
but that's not the same as saying it's a
boon to our species
we may have been better off and
healthier when we were on the cycles of
the sun
when we did have a broader expanse of of
information so i thought that was a
good cautionary note that he sounded
he's a very wise man as you well yeah
he is a very wise man have you ever
this might seem like a non-sequitur but
have you ever explored
coffee culture in japan have you looked
at all
their coffee culture it's really
fascinating which is a which is a lazy
adjective but
you see a lot of the sort of meticulous
attention to detail
that you might associate with a tea
ceremony
brought into these elaborate rituals in
some places around coffee now of course
you can get your like
dime store shitty coffee yeah first
thing in the morning to go to your job
but
there are also these uh these
can be spoke hole-in-the-wall places
where you can get a 45-minute pour over
and they have lots of rules around what
what you can do or can't do with their
coffee
they might give you a piece of toast
there's a place called you know kashira
park
where i remember going to this uh this
coffee shop which
it was fancy but it wasn't expensive if
that makes any sense
they took it very very seriously and
they sold two things they sold
coffee and they sold they sold
toast that had the face of a
panda bear burned into the side and
those are the two things that you could
purchase
so the coffee was great the coffee was
fantastic
and for those people interested there's
a
term it's kisateng or kisa sometimes
k-i-s-s-a there are a number of videos
that you can find on youtube
looking at this sort of kissa culture
k-i-s-s-a
and actually i've been meaning to ask
you have you done
anything in video or television
related to how to change your mind
funny you should ask yesterday i was
shooting for a documentary series that
we're doing
on how to change your mind i've been
working on it for the last several
months
and it's going to be a four-part netflix
series looking at four different
substances we're going to look at
lsd psilocybin mdma
and mesclun and do an hour on each so
i'm very excited by it you know i've
done this with previous books cooked was
a four-part netflix series and
botany of desire was on public
television and i i'm very interested in
how you translate one medium into an
into another but also you know you just
reach people you don't reach not
everybody reads books
books are the germ but it's really
important to reach people where they are
yeah so i'm hoping by the end of the
year or or early next year it'll be
it'll drop that's super exciting the
visual medium also
is a great gateway drug
pun intended for the longer form
writing also i would imagine a lot of
people will discover
your writing and have discovered your
writing through without question
yeah they start they watch it on
television and then they realized
there's a book
yeah that's definitely part of it our
challenge though in doing this
is how do you recreate the psychedelic
experience not using
paisley visuals and and the instructions
to the the special effects people that
we interviewed
and we found a fantastic firm that's
doing
some amazing sequences is no 60s
references
no paisley no kaleidoscopes because that
was never right anyway that's just yeah
that was the technology they had
to make things look weird so they're
coming up with some very new ways to
imagine the psychedelic experience for
the screen
and that's what i'm most excited about
can't wait to see it
my last question i guess is in a way
also related to gateway drugs
metaphorically speaking gardening if i'm
going to
step into the world of gardening and
recognizing that i am
prone to starting many things but i
don't continue many things
so if i want to start off on the right
foot and not read any textbooks or
anything to begin with
are there any resources any suggested
starting points things to do maybe first
projects how do i even begin to approach
this because gardening
is so broad a term yeah it just includes
so much
and i will have some property
on the east coast i can kind of do
whatever i want
i could also do something in texas
so i have options available where would
you suggest that i start
well are you interested in in growing
food
or growing ornamental or growing psych
or
growing psychoactives
i would be open to all of them i think
i'm interested in food
kind of depends on the turnaround time
on the food since i i'm not in one place
all year round and i know nothing about
harvesting schedules and so on
i'm very interested in growing culinary
herbs
for instance i could see growing tobacco
possibly
if that is kosher your book scared the
lord oh
[ __ ] out of me when it came to growing
oh no it's completely
i i grow tobacco too and it's a
beautiful plant and an
unjustly maligned plant i would i would
argue
beautiful plant that i've seen in
travels through
mexico and elsewhere takes a lot of
space it's a big
yeah i think what would be interesting
to me
is having a few plants or a few projects
that
teach me a lot about different
principles
of gardening if that makes any sense
without biting more often i can chew
well one way to start i mean not having
seen your property or know that much i
know it gets very hot in austin
in this summer is to build a raised bed
start with one raised bed which
you buy some wood that doesn't decay
easily like cedar or redwood
and you make a box essentially that's
about
a foot high and it can be any length
you want but it shouldn't be so wide
that you can't reach every point
in it and fill it with soil you know
which you can either get at the garden
center or have
a dump truck come over the advantage of
a raised bed is it's
kind of idyllic circumstances for the
plants whatever the
local issues are with your soil are not
you know and if you're living if you
have an old house there may be lead in
your soil so it's
you want to test your soil if you're
going to use local soil for food or
herbs
and it gives you this ideal growing
medium because the land has never
stepped on so it doesn't get compressed
so
the roots can really travel and you can
plant more densely in a raised bed
because the roots can go down rather
than sideways
there's a book called square foot
gardening that's really good john
jeevans
who is an englishman who really was one
of the pioneers of
organic gardening and he was a great
believer in
raised beds and in that you can
experiment and you could take one
end and do all herbs and herbs are
wonderful in that they don't need a lot
of attention
most of them are pretty tough some are
annuals and they'll die every year like
basil you have to replant every year but
many of them will reseed or just come up
on their own again
and you know i have a house that i don't
visit that often
and all i plant now there i used to have
this is the house where the
opium story took place i'm gonna still
own it and i only plant
herbs and garlic now because they can do
very well without me
garlic is the best crop because you
plant it in the fall
and ignore it and whether it's dry or
wet
it will come up and it has no pests
bother it it's absolutely
foolproof and very easy to plant you
just buy big cloves of garlic
in the market in the fall and divide
them up into single cloves
and stick them in the ground and they'll
do their thing
you need a house call i have to come i
have to come visit and look at the city
you need to come visit
you do need to come visit i i endorse
that suggestion
yeah start with john jeevans though he's
uh that was a big influence on me when i
started gardening
and uh square foot garden and watch out
for those woodchucks
you know there are i there are no wood
chucks that i'm aware of here in austin
but we do have armadillos i imagine
they're pretty enthusiastic about eating
anything and everything
they can get their uh prehistoric paws
on
but dear do you have deer there are a
deer here
uh not nearly as many as you would find
certainly in a rural part of the east
coast
so you'll you'll learn pretty quickly
what your pests are yeah
because when when the news gets around
the neighborhood that there's some good
vittles
uh everybody shows up
and and then you then you have to start
thinking in terms of fences and things
like that
just a quick interruption and we'll be
right back to the show the book
suggested and referenced by michael from
john jevens
jevins is j-e-a-v-o-n-s is actually
titled
how to grow more vegetables the subtitle
is than you ever thought possible on
less land with less water than you can
imagine and there is a forward by alice
waters so once again
it is john jevens j-e-a-v-o-n-s
and the title is how to grow more
vegetables we'll link to it in the show
notes on tim dot blog
slash podcast now back to the show
michael it's always so much fun
people can find you online at
michaelpollen.com
michaelpollen on twitter michael.pollen
on instagram the new book
is this is your mind on plants it's just
a fascinating
romp through history your own
personal adventures and fear and
loathing in connecticut of course
in one portion and i always enjoy
your writing and also our time in
conversation is there anything else that
you would like
to say any closing comments any requests
of people listening anything at all that
you'd like to add before we
wind down this conversation i don't
think so i think we've covered a lot of
ground as
as usual it's always a pleasure talking
to you we have so many interests in
common
this is always a labor of love so anyway
thank you
thank you michael to be continued i'm
going to take you up on that house call
offer and for everybody listening as
mentioned
earlier we will have show notes copious
show notes for everything
that we discussed you can find links to
everything descriptions and so on at tim
dot blog forward slash podcast
just search michael pollan and look for
the most
recent episode and until next time thank
you
for tuning in hey guys this is tim again
just a few more things before you take
off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just
a little tiny bite of goodness before
you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
four hourworkweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
headspace headspace is your daily dose
of mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2 000 plus
apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
its faces backed by 25 published studies
on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million
downloads so if people keep telling you
to try meditation and you're like when
would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers
a really light lift and a lot
of features to keep you going which is
part of the reason that i've used
headspace for years now so whatever the
situation headspace can really help you
feel better overwhelmed headspace has a
three minute sos meditation view need
some help falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions their
members swear by and for parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can do with your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder andy i think
it's a puddicom
could be putty comb i'm not sure but
former monk turned into co-founder
of headspace has the most soothing
hypnotic voice imaginable
and i did a three minute meditation
something like that it's easy
it's fundamental and it always puts me
in
a better space so i'm going through the
basics even though i've meditated for
years i'm going through the basics
once again and i would suggest to anyone
that they
consider starting there headspace makes
it easy for you to build a life-changing
meditation practice with mindfulness
that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere we all
want to feel happier
we all want more peace and headspace is
meditation made
simple go to headspace.com tim
that's headspace.com tim for a free one
month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break a glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace
this is the best deal offered right now
for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim today this episode is brought to you
by
eight sleep my god am i in love with
eight sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30
of americans struggle with sleep and i'm
a member of that sad roof temperature
is one of the main causes of poor sleep
and heat has always been my nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight sleep
it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures
on either side which is exactly what
we're doing now for me
and for many people the result eight
sleep users fall asleep up to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250
off of the pod pro cover that's a lot
simply go to eight
sleep dot com slash tim or use code tim
that's eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code temp tim eightsleep.com
tim for 200 off your pod pro cover
you